la tension monte entre moscou et
l'occident le kremlin a répondu aux
accusations américaines selon lesquelles
la russie préparait une invasion de
l'ukraine à des informations un démenti
par le service russe de renseignement
extérieur il affirme que ces allégations
pourrait avoir de très graves
conséquences plus de détails avec notre
correspondante à moscou mais il estrie
mensongère c'est ainsi que le service
russe de renseignement extérieur a
qualifié ce lundi les informations
fournies par le département d'état
américain
il affirme que la russie mobiliserait
des troupes sur son territoire dans le
but d'envahir l'ukraine le svr estime
que washington attend un signe d'affoler
la communauté internationale en agitant
une prétendue menace russe ces
accusations ont été reprise par de
nombreux médias occidentaux
d'après certaines informations le
département d'état américain par la voie
diplomatique communique des informations
totalement fausses sur la concentration
de troupes sur notre territoire en vue
d'une invasion militaire en ukraine nous
sommes inquiets qu'une telle propagande
agressive pousse le régime de kiev a
augmenté ses effectifs militaires dans
le donbass à renouveler des tirs
d'artillerie sur des sites civils le
service russe de renseignement extérieur
reprochent aux états unis et à l'union
européenne ou politique provocatrice qui
je cite renforce délibérément le
sentiment de permissivité et d'impunité
de kiev le porte parole de vladimir
poutine a également réagi ce lundi aux
déclarations américaines en affirmant
que les mouvements de troupes russes en
russie ne représentait de menace pour
personne pour rappel le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken avait
déclaré ce samedi que les états unis
était sérieusement préoccupé par les
activités militaires inhabituel de la
russie à la frontière avec l'ukraine
ajoutant que ces inquiétudes étaient
largement partagé par les alliés de
washington